This parabola has a vertex at 2,3 right here. Nice work if you got this
correct. Just like before, we'll take our equation and we'll try to complete
the square this time for the y terms. The b value here is negative 6, so b over
2 is negative 3. And b over 2 squared equals 9, the square of this number. So,
we know we need to add 9 in order to make a perfect square here, but I can't
just add 9 to an equation since I'll change it. So, if I add 9 here I should
also subtract 9 that will make it balanced, I really added 0. We rewrite this
part as a perfect square. And now we can just combine these two numbers on the
end. This gives us an equation in vertex form. And notice that it's x equals,
so we know the parabola will open to the left, or to the right. Since there's a
positive 1 in front of our square term, we know that a is 1, so our parabola
opens to the right. For a horizontal parabola, the x coordinate of the vertex
is here. It's h. The y coordinate of the vertex is k, and it's here. It's
positive 3. We can find the y value of the vertex by setting y minus 3 equal to
0. So, we know x is positive 2, and y would be positive 3. Now that we have the
vertex let's figure out how to graph our parabola and know that it opens this
way. The a value is always in front of the squared term. So, a here is still
positive 1 so let's zoom in our vertex and figure out how to graph those other
two points. Here is our vertex at 2, 3 and now we go a units in the x
direction. So, we'll go 1 unit up and one unit down from our vertex. Then we'll
go 1 unit right and 1 unit right. This gives us our two other points and 3,4
and 3,2.